[Musique]
très heureux de vous retrouver sur
france24 merci de votre fidélité au
journal de l'afrique au sommaire les
réactions au sénégal après le choix
décisif de pape diop celui de rallier la
coalition pouvoir le député offre ainsi
la majorité absolue au camp présidentiel
vous entendrez l'opposition
au moins un mort au niger un civil tués
dans l'explosion d'une mine au
nord-ouest de niamey une zone est
régulièrement visée par des engins
artisanaux
nous serons sur place
et puis suite et fin de notre série
consacrée à la biennale de ouidah au
bénin a consacré à la culture vaudou
l'épisode du jour nous emmènera sur les
bancs de l'école nous verrons comment
coutume rime avec modernité
pape diop a donc mis fin au suspense une
semaine après la publication des
résultats aux législatives sénégalaise
l'ancien maire de dakar a rallié la
coalition pouvoir il veut éviter à son
pays dit il une crise institutionnelle
le dépité le député et permettent ainsi
au camp présidentiel d'obtenir 83 sièges
donc la majorité absolue les réactions
24 heures après ce choix décisifs
recueillis par un et linda
hains rejoignent à la coalition au
pouvoir c'est pape diop qui permet à
banimmo qatar d'avoir la majorité
absolue à l'assemblée nationale au
lendemain de sa déclaration très
commentée par la presse et par lous
pignots placier maire de dakar et
l'ancien président de l'assemblée
nationale estime avoir pris ce choix en
toute responsabilité
j'ai après mûre réflexion
décidé de soutenir la coalition
que le groupe parlementaire de benno
bouaké aka mettra sur place pour éviter
à notre pays
des situations dramatiques parce qu'on
aurait pu assister à un blocage
institutionnel
je n'ai jamais fait des calculs
politiques parce que moi je me suis
toujours fondées sur le fruit de mon
travail et non sur la politique
l'interco addition d'opposition et
askanwi où elle loue sénégal qui
totalisent ensemble à 80 députés
estiment toujours faire partie des plus
grandes forces politiques de ce pays
écoutez à moussavi fait partie des
leaders de la coalition d'opposition il
est-ce qu à lui pas pu aller à la quête
de surface en se présentant
à ce titre là il a été élu député si
aujourd'hui il va rejoindre le camp
présidentiel ça ne s'appelle pas autre
chose ça s'appelle un détournement de
deux suffrages
ce qui est bizarre c'est que ça n'a pas
surpris mais ça ne regarde tout le monde
s'attendait déjà à ses tubes à la
quatorzième législature du sénégal va
entrer en service mi septembre ce sera à
moins de deux ans de la prochaine
présidentielle en 2024
l'explosion a eu lieu à quelques
encablures de niamey une mine a tué au
moins un civil au nord-ouest de la
capitale nigérienne sur la route qui
mène au burkina faso ces derniers mois
les attaques djihadistes s'y sont
multipliés alors que le niger multiplie
ses partenariats à l'étranger
correspondance de harold girard un
véhicule retourné complètement détruit
et un trou béant ce sont les premières
images auxquelles nous avons eu accès
par rapport à l'incident et d'hier
l'explosion a eu lieu dans la zone du
village de bouma 10 km à peine de niamey
dans une zone encore très fréquenté par
les habitants de la capitale cette route
qui mène au burkina faso est
régulièrement la cible pour ses
installations d'engins explosifs
improvisés des extrémistes puisqu'ils
sont allés jusqu'à détruire une partie
de la route goudronnée pour tenter d'y
installer ses mines la situation à la
frontière avec le burkina faso est
encore plus tendue cette année
qu'auparavant des transports commerciaux
sont régulièrement annulé pour raisons
sécuritaires et les liaisons opérées par
les compagnies de bus entre les deux
pays ont pris un coup énorme cette année
beaucoup de voyageurs ont dû reporter de
plusieurs mois leur voyage et certains
asie cinéraire ne sont totalement plus
envisageable la dégradation sécuritaire
dans le nord du burkina faso de manière
générale mais aussi dans le mali voisin
sont les deux principales causes de la
re montée de l'insécurité ici dans la
région nigérienne de tillabéri
dans l'actualité du continent également
road kaboré a quitté le burkina première
fois depuis le coup d'état qui l'a
renversé le 24 janvier dernier l'ancien
président et aux émirats arabes unis
pour un exil examen médical avant cela
il s'est rendu à abidjan en côte
d'ivoire pour une rencontre privée avec
alassane ouattara
l'allemagne suspens pour l'instant ces
opérations militaires au mali des
missions de reconnaissance et transports
au sein de la minus ma la raison les
autorités maliennes ils ont refusé un
vol qui devait effectuer une rotation de
personnel bamako qui ces derniers mois
s'est éloigné de paris et rapprocher de
moscou et puis en ethiopie le grand
barrage de la renaissance avance à
grands pas la deuxième détresse turbines
au du projet a été mis en marche au
grand dam de l'egypte et du soudan y
voit une menace pour leur
approvisionnement en eau le premier
ministre habib ahmed a voulu rassurer il
s'est défendu de nuire à ses voisins
16 août 2012 le nord de l'afrique du sud
était endeuillée une grève de salariés
de la mine de mary canard était
violemment réprimées trente quatre
personnes ont été tuées 78 blessés dix
ans après certains policiers ont été
traduits en justice aucun n'a été
condamné quant aux indemnisations des
familles des victimes promise par le
gouvernement elles manquent à l'appel
c'est la police qui a tué mon frère
parce qu'ils avaient dit que la police
était arrivée et leur avait tiré dessus
alors qu'ils étaient sur la colline
il m'a mise debout là je ne sais
toujours pas pourquoi il a été tué tout
ce que je sais c'est qu'il y avait une
grève
poireautent couple c'est très douloureux
pour nous parce que nous savons que nous
allons perdre une partie de nos vies
alors maintenant
nous voyons que même le gouvernement
ne se soucie pas de nous
ils ne font rien au moins six essais de
faire quelque chose cela fait dix ans
maintenant que nos vies auraient dû
changer pour le mieux
au lieu de cela
m se sont qu'empirer
ios
pour réduire les effets de l'inflation
sur le porte monnaie des ivoiriens le
gouvernement met les bouchées doubles
dans sa ligne de mire les biens de
première nécessité
certains coûts ont été plafonnées et des
brigades mis en place pour faire
respecter la loi reportage à abidjan de
samuel bernard
visite surprise des contrôleurs des prix
dans cette boulangerie de l'est
d'abidjan depuis le 20 juillet l'état
ivoirien vérifie que les établissements
vendent bien des baguettes au prix
obligatoire de 150 et 200 francs dont le
poids a été fixé par les autorités comme
cette boulangerie rares sont les
établissements a réellement proposer ses
prix la majorité ne respectent pas ce
que le gouvernement dit alors ce qu'ils
apprennent qu'il y à un contrôle la zone
ils font exprès d'étaler ou du moins
d'exposer une petite quantité juste pour
tromper la vigilance des l'arrière les
pêcheurs face à la montée des prix en
côte d'ivoire le gouvernement a annoncé
une batterie de mesures dont le
plafonnement de 21 produits de grande
consommation tels que le riz l'huile ou
la tomate concentrée mais nombreux sont
les commerçants à ne pas pouvoir
respecter ces règles deux mille d'entre
eux auraient déjà été épinglée pour
non-respect du blocage des prix selon
cet épicier la raison est simple
impossible de conserver les mêmes tarifs
qu'en les fournisseurs augmentent les
îles et augmenter la battait pour cela
nous arrange bien les plus féconds et
enfin la vallasse et pour cela nous
sommes comme ça là bas c'est ça de vue
menées
avec la subvention de certains produits
la campagne de contrôle des prix à
travers des brigade d'inspecteurs est
l'une des mesures phare de la lutte
contre la vie chère mais pour cet
économiste
il s'agit avant tout d'une campagne de
communication
ça n'aura aucun effet parce que cette
brigade vont aller de boulangerie en
boulangerie de magasin en magasin et
quand les gens vont aller voir venir les
gens vont changer les prix il ya
diverses manières de d'adressé ce
problème d'inflation et en côte d'ivoire
on n'est pas en train de l'adresser de
la bonne manière selon les prévisions de
la banque africaine de développement
l'inflation en côte d'ivoire pourrait
atteindre les 5 4% en 2022 en raison des
tensions générées par la guerre en
ukraine
allez on vous emmène au bénin à ouidah
ou la biennale met à l'honneur la
culture vodoun focus ce soir sur l'école
ou comment concilier l'éducation
traditionnelle dispensés dans les
couvents vaudou et celle moderne des
établissements scolaires reportage
d'emmanuel zaki
au bénin la ville de ouidah est connu
pour son ancien port négrier
mais c'est aussi le siège du date bourg
ou non le chef suprême des culte vaudou
et voici celle qui saura terme intronisé
reine de toutes les divinités la fille
de l'actuel régnant
à se poser quand je serai plus âgé je
serai une grande prêtresse
il y a trente ans une fois que ses
enfants avaient été recueillis dans un
couvent pour leur formation au secret de
la tradition vaudou ils n'étaient plus
autorisés à aller à l'école pourtant
certains responsables religieux ont
compris très tôt l'intérêt de
l'enseignement académique
quand on met ainsi sur
la future prêtresse suit des cours dans
une école très particulière reconnue par
l'état combinant à la fois enseignement
académique du primaire et éducation
traditionnelle
les enfants qui sont ici que sont
capables de bien fondre l'intérêt de la
tradition de la cci les cuivres ça veut
dire que vous aurez la réalité avec la
modernisation de la société les couvents
ont vu leur nombre de fidèles diminué il
a fallu s'adapter pour freiner
l'hémorragie
passé l'initiation ou deux à trois ans
un an
ici l'initiation est passé de 3 en un an
nous avions compris que c'était
difficile de mettre un enfant deux ou
trois ans au pouvoir il faudrait que
l'on puisse avoir des enfants dès 4 ans
avant leur entrée aux primaires une
sensibiliser le gouvernement pour cela
on siège de l'ancien royaume d'abomey
même ceux qui ne sont pas adeptes du
vaudou sont désormais formés au danse et
au chant sacré au sein d'un
conservatoire national auparavant on les
a prenait uniquement dans le secret des
couvents vodoun
un groupe restreint peut garder très
solidement quelque chose mais cas c'est
inscrit dans le coeur tu as la même d'un
peuple ça se conserve sur un long moment
le conservatoire nationale recrute ses
meilleurs talents au sein des écoles
d'abomey ou à présent on transmet le
patrimoine immatériel de l'ancien plus
grand royaume du pis
aller le journal les afriques c'est fini
pour aujourd'hui merci de nous avoir
suivis retrouver nous aussi sur france
24 points comme et nos réseaux sociaux
prenez soin de vous excellent week-end à
lundi
[Musique]